the 61st annual the company Wars is
being brought to you by Kodak color
cookies color as you can love coca-cola
classic you can't beat the feeling GE
from aircraft engines to appliances we
bring good things to life and Revlon the
most unforgettable women in the world
where Revlon ladies and gentlemen miss
Carrie Fisher as mr. Martin Short
Martin how did this happen
Carrie I'm sorry
Martin I uh I took you to the store you
you saw me buy the dress you knew I was
gonna wear it to the Academy Awards you
knew this was a special occasion for me
you knew I wanted to look particularly
distinctive Carrie you have hundreds of
dresses
I have four
this was my moment at the Oscars and you
pretty much destroyed it by humiliating
me in front of millions of people just
because of your desperate need for
attention
uh so what are you saying
you want me go change alright I'll
change but the shoes stay
men you can't live with them and you
can't kill them in the category of best
animated short films the nominees are
Cordell Barker for the cat came back
bill Pryor and Brian Jennings for
technological threat
John Lasseter and William Reeves for tin
toy and the Oscar goes to tin toy John
Lasker and William Rees
oh this is great Joey we did it
we'd like to thank the Academy for this
great honor because it's the first time
this award has gone to a computer
animated film we'd like to share this
with the computer graphics community the
world around but the computers didn't
create the films people did we'd like to
thank those people at Pixar firstly Evan
Osby who should be on stage with us
tonight great job at Ralph Guggenheim
great good give drew Warren Susan
Anderson just everybody else statement
on Steve Jobs thank you very much
in the category of Best live action
short film the nominees I'm already now
I'm sorry did I miss anything we're
doing a live action short oh that's good
Fisher oh I seem to I got you shook keys
there's nice you know the first time at
the Oscars and they named an award up me
his one pause the nominees are Dean
Paris oh and Stephen right for the
appointments of Dennis Jennings Marty a
Carell and Abby goldstein for Cadillac
dreams
Gary moss and George to go in for gullet
tails and the Oscar goes to the
appointments of Dennis Jennings gene
Perico and skating right
um this is to the short film category
and we're really glad that we cut out
the other 60 minutes
we'd like to thank David picker Paul a
Mazur Mike Armstrong co-writer Paul
Jackson and I'd like to personally thank
Peter Sally and Johnny Carson we'd also
like to thank HBO Alive films the
Academy and Sally my wife thank you
thank you ladies and gentlemen Academy
award-winning actor Michael Douglas
Academy award-winning producer Michael
Douglas